لقي أكثر من أربعة ملايين شخص مصرعهم حتى الآن بسبب فيروس كورونا في جميع أنحاء العالم. حالة طوارئ مرغوبة وأعلنت أنه لن يُسمح للجمهور بالتواجد في الألعاب ، دعني أبدأ معك وأسأل ما يبدو لي أنه القصة الإخبارية الكبيرة هنا في جائحة اعتقدنا أنه نوع من التهدئة وبالتأكيد في الولايات المتحدة ، لقد دخلنا عالم ما بعد الجائحة وهو متغير دلتا هذا الذي تم اكتشافه في الهند العام الماضي وهو الآن في 96 دولة ، نصف الحالات الجديدة في الولايات المتحدة هي متغير دلتا ، ما الذي يجب أن نعرفه عن هذا نعم لذلك سيصبح متغير دلتا هو السلالة المهيمنة في جميع أنحاء العالم إذا تمكنا من النظر إلى ما يحدث في بريطانيا الآن ، فقد تحول من كونه نسبة صغيرة من الحالات  لكونها
غالبية الحالات التي نجدها
ولسوء الحظ أنها أكثر قابلية للانتقال
مما يعني أنه من الصعب قمع
باستخدام نفس السياسات التي
استخدمناها في الماضي من بعض النواحي ،
فقد أصبح التحدي أكبر
من حيث  تقليل الاختلاط في محاولة
لوقف انفجار الحالات
على الجانب الإيجابي يبدو أن
لقاحاتنا معطلة
ولكن هناك حاجة إلى
جرعتين من اللقاحات ليس واحدة فقط ،
لذا فهو يمثل تحديًا ولكن لحسن الحظ
لا تزال اللقاحات تعمل حتى الآن ،
ما سمعته هو مرتين  باعتبارها
قابلة للانتقال ، ما الذي يحتاج المرء إلى معرفته من حيث مدى خطورته جيدًا ، هناك بعض
الأشياء التي تكون
واضحة حقًا أولاً ، فهي على الأقل
معدية مرتين مثل السلالة الأصلية
وهذا يعني
أننا سنحصل على  للحصول على مستوى أعلى
من المناعة لوقف
الانتشار المتفجر ، ولكن كما يقول ديفي ، فإن
اللقاحات تعمل
بشكل جيد ضدها ، على الرغم من أنك
ربما تحتاج إلى جرعتين من لقاح mrna من أجل الحصول على
جرعة كاملة
هذا أمر
مهم حقًا لأن ذلك
يستغرق شهرًا أو شهرين لبدء العمل ، لذلك كلما تم
تطعيم الأشخاص في وقت مبكر ، كان من الأفضل بشكل
أساسي أن يكون الفتيل أقصر بين
الوقت الذي
تبدأ فيه الحالات في الانتشار وعندما تحصل على
انتشار متفجر ،
نشهد بالفعل زيادات في
المملكة المتحدة
وإسرائيل التي لديها مستويات عالية من
التطعيم في الولايات المتحدة ، فنحن على
نحو متزايد
دولتان مقسمتان تحت Kovit أحدهما محصن
إلى حد كبير وهو
ذو معدلات منخفضة جدًا وقد يشهد بعض
الزيادات ولكن ربما لا يكون متفجراً
والآخر لديه معدلات تطعيم منخفضة
حيث نحن بالفعل  رؤية
مضاعفة الحالات أسبوعًا بعد أسبوع في بعض
الولايات
وستستمر هذه الزيادات حتمًا
وسنراهم يتبعهم
للأسف المزيد من حالات دخول المستشفى والمزيد من الوفيات
، ولهذا السبب فإن
تكثيف التطعيم
مهم للغاية وكما تقول
في إفريقيا فإن 1.2 بالمائة فقط من
الناس  تلقيحًا كاملًا وهذا
أمر غير مقبول تمامًا ،
فنحن بحاجة إلى القيام بعمل أفضل بكثير أولاً لإعادة
تخصيص
كل ما هو متاح  هي اللقاحات الحالية
والثانية
تكثيف الإنتاج بأسرع ما
يمكن
حتى لا يكون لدينا عام أو عامين
من هذا الوباء المدمر
مع عدم إنتاج لقاح كافٍ تقريبًا في
جميع أنحاء العالم ،
لذا ستصبح دلتا هي
البديل السائد لأن ما يحدث أساسًا
هو لأنه  ضعف العدوى ، على
الأقل هذا الذي ينشر
ألفا يموت الآن ولذا ينتهي بنا الأمر
مع المزيد مما تعرفه لذا فإن الوباء هو
في الواقع في بعض النواحي في الغالبية العظمى
من العالم غير
الملقح ، أصبح الوباء الآن
معديًا مرتين مثل  اعتقدنا أنه
كان وبالطبع ما يقلقني هو أن هذا
يعني أن البديل التالي يمكن أن يكون
معديًا مرتين مثل دلتا
جيدًا ، نعم لا نعرف ما هو
قاب قوسين أو أدنى ، وهذا ما نراه
الآن مع دلتا يجعل البرية الأصلية
اكتب stars kobe 2 تبدو
أبسط بكثير في قمعها وإدارتها ، لذا
نعم ، أعني أنه سيكون هناك
المزيد من المتغيرات القابلة للانتقال
قادمة في المستقبل وعلينا
الاستعداد  من أجل ذلك ،
فإن التشبيه بالنسبة لي هو سباقات السيارات التي
تعرف أن النسخة الأصلية كانت 60 ميلاً في
الساعة ، والألفا التالية كانت 90 ميلاً في
الساعة ، ثم تأتي دلتا على طول
120 ميلاً في الساعة ،
يصبح الأمر أصعب وأصعب ، كما أن
هدف توم  قال أين يجب أن
نصل إليه من حيث التطعيم ،
كيف أن النسبة المئوية للسكان
لوقف النمو المستمر
تجعلك تعرف أكثر فأكثر
بعيدًا ، إنه ليس مستحيلًا ولكنه
يتطلب
نقل هذه الجرعات إلى جميع أنحاء
العالم مع استمرار الناس مع
الصعوبة  مقاييس التباعد عن
ارتداء أغطية الوجه عندما يكونون في
الداخل لتجنب الاختلاط وكذلك استخدام
اختباراتنا قدر الإمكان للعثور على
الحالات وكسر
سلاسل النقل التي تعرفها
متى أمكنك ذلك